alright should more be going public Marc
Benioff has been outspoken saying stop
avoiding the public markets if you're a
good company if you know how to lead go
public
get tested yeah read blog post yeah read
blog posts saying the exact same thing
and I've been a proponent to that level
for a long time
a couple different things what's
happening in the market right now
there's a dearth of high and high growth
companies right so now we look at
Facebook Netflix Google as you know the
hyper growth companies when there are
hyper growth is behind them they're
still growing quickly what's happening
now is the hyper growth in public
company private companies is being
bought out by private investors right I
don't know that uber is gonna accelerate
their growth their growth rates are
probably going to decline those early
investors can't get out they can't get
out they're stuck right and so I I think
you know now with reg a plus there's two
versions of 20 million version a 50
million dollar version I'm actually
working with a couple different banking
groups to say look let's go out and find
companies that have 30 million in
revenue a hundred percent plus annual
growth you know 10% net profits
after-tax and let's start finding ways
to use a plus to go public because that
accomplished several things one it gives
investors a liquid way to invest in
hyper growth companies which i think is
great for the market because it doesn't
exist right now it's great for the
company that's going public because of
you know the visibility the liquidity
the cash that's raised the liquidity for
their investors the quiddity for their
employees just so much upside makes it
easier to raise more capital and the
whole argument that now you're beholden
to the market and corley earnings is
nonsense right because what's worse than
having your stock get crushed like
linkedin is having your sales not meet
expectations of private investors having
multiple down rounds when you go out and
try to raise equity and now you have no
shot of going out and getting public
then why stick with your sharks you
mentioned twitter earlier why not knock
on Jack Dorsey's door it sounds like he
could help right now would you want to
in what way not gonna why not invest in
Twitter I think the price is still a
little bit too high I think it Twitter
is very fixable
but I think they have that whole Silicon
Valley mentality that kind of works
against them
would you take a board seat if fast I
talked to them
see I think Twitter's so fixable and it
has so many things that they can do
right how could you fix them what would
you do you have to call me to find out
about Yahoo fixable I don't know enough
about the details anymore I mean you
know you look at them and if you compare
their expense based off you know a
Twitter right there much more bloated
and Marissa is going out there to try to
make those changes
I think Yahoo has a lot of core value
but again Silicon Valley that mindset
out there that look culture matters and
Silicon Valley has a very specific
culture so it's the old Hollywood
culture and you know the if when you
hear about the old casting couch days of
Hollywood from 30 50 years ago and you
talk you'd hear stories about people
saying they're always looking over your
shoulder for the next bigger star the
next better script in Silicon Valley now
everybody's logo is looking over your
shoulder for the next startup the better
startup the bigger unicorn the Decker
corn right people just don't dig in and
go to work and I think you know Dallas
Austin you know Boston New York there's
so many places right now Minneapolis
that are Pittsburgh that are hyper
growth for startups that the culture
makes it so much better for growth
companies that I think Silicon Valley
has become a significant negative
there's only one good thing about
Silicon Valley that's what the people
who create the exits are right there's
people who will buy your company they're
the VC firms have all have the
connections we'll find you someone else
to buy we'll find a greater fool to buy
your company and the Silicon Valley is
better than that than anywhere else in
the world mark then why not go bigger
why wouldn't you want to become a
constructive activist you clearly
understand the markets you understand
companies but you also understand
culture leadership entrepreneurship so
the the criticism of activists investors
is well they only know how to play the
market but they don't know how to turn
around a company so you could do both
here's what I do every Friday night on
ABC on Shark Tank and with all the
replays there's 20 million people that
watched any given episode and I'm but
those are small companies not the point
the bigger point the the more important
part the reason I do the show is every
single Friday night and all those
repeats reinforce reinforce the message
that the Americans
is alive and well and if there's some
ten-year-old boy or girl that's watching
and in the back of their mind there's
just an amazing idea and we give them
confidence to go out and start that
company we extend the message to them
that being an entrepreneur is amazing
it's a great thing to do if I if we can
do just one of those two of those five
of those and have that spread that's far
more than I can ever do as an activist
you don't look at IBM and think I got a
step in there and turn it around
oh hell no I look at IBM and say Watson
better work or they're in trouble do you
think it is working I think it has a
chance
yeah but iBM has become so financially
engineering driven with all the stock
buybacks and you know they've got some
great technology there but it doesn't
really drive their business yet